in here they say they're not engaged in
a vaccine export ban
countries wanting to get jabs from
europe are likely to think otherwise
the european commission wants to know
where vaccines produce this side of the
channel
are going to and if that's justified
what they call the principles of
transparency reciprocity
and proportionality it insists it does
not have its sights set on any
particular nation
but cited what it saw as an unequal
relationship
with the uk just since the introduction
of the export authorization system
some 10 million doses had been exported
from
uk from eu to uk
and zero doses had been exported from uk
to eu
the two sides could also fall out over
the eu's new focus on looking at
countries vaccination rates
when considering exports the uk is doing
well
but only around 10 of the eu population
has received jabs
two weeks ago a shipment of astrazeneca
vaccines was blocked from being sent
from italy to australia
because the need was deemed greater in
europe and astrazeneca has been forced
to issue a statement
saying 29 million doses of vaccine
currently in italy
are not intended for export except to
poorer countries
astrazeneca's failure to deliver tens of
millions of vaccines to the eu
infuriated the commission and partly
explains the move
to toughen up export rules but many warn
the eu is playing a dangerous game
because europe relies on imports of
components and ingredients
from all over the world to make its
vaccines
this uk facility in yorkshire for
example produces elements for the fires
of bayern tech factories
in the eu pfizer has said that the free
movement of goods and supply across
borders is critical a sentiment boris
johnson echoed
i don't think that blockades of uh
of either vaccines or of um
medicines of of ingredients for vaccines
are
sensible and i think that the long-term
damage done
by blockades can be can be very
considerable
the eu rejects any notion of blockades
on its part
but will fear any counter-reaction
europe is confronting a third wave and
struggling despite that germany has
dropped a five-day lockdown over easter
but belgium has tightened restrictions
once again
with rising case numbers in the eu the
pressure to get more vaccines
will only intensify michelle clifford
sky news
brussels